yeah they put a microphone by it yeah of
course yeah what do I do
Adrian you might be television copy
dance so this game is cool I haven't
played all these oh but you're still the
switch expert okay oh this stinks I'm
not doing this it's copy dance so so one
of you is gonna do a dance and then the
other one has to copy it okay do we know
why do you need to play this on switch
why can't you just play copy it's just
part of it I don't know I don't I can
never buy this on my own
yeah so like why would you what the
purpose to switch have how is it not
just like because because you're using
these these are like motion simulator
yeah not motion simulator sensors yeah
okay how do I play against the computer
I want to play Zelda no right now you
got to play copy dance with Derek I
don't want to play copy - well you have
to I don't come on let's play copy dance
no it's not fun for the listeners it's
it's great for the list okay so alright
so attach your strap to what what do you
think and is all how to do this I'm here
is it attached to your wrist yeah I'm
holding you okay d-bag is it attached to
your wrist you guys ready to come wait
mine's upside down oh no no no no you
can't do that it's kind of yeah
turn it around hit any button wait
where's the any button any button now
why is it okay copy dance now who's
gonna go there's an Ellen R on the
screen
okay are okay now you hit L Jim I'm not
enjoying this oh yeah because L is like
player 2 because it's a left and a right
side right so Jim's got the left
controller and Dericks didn't hit a
button okay al is ready to go anybody
filming there okay now it's time to copy
dance this not being you're gonna dance
first Jimbo okay Derrick you [ __ ]
okay Oh three times now what
okay face each other with your hands in
front of youse ready okay Jim your left
look at ya Derek Oh Jim not you Derek
not yet
now you copy pose Jim another one
another one another one
he's grabbing his balls okay that's true
it's now Derek you posed hate this oh
Christ she's making a Chippendale pose
okay Derek oh okay okay now you copy
that oh I hate this game all right all
right we do we just copy dance this game
just terribly see the result all it's
done mom I lost Derek is the winner so
the three poses the three poses which is
arguably the worst form of entertainment
I'd rather play scat games he is
terrible the three poses that Derek was
able to copy were a cupping of the
breasts grabbing of the crotch and then
once the third one you guys are gonna
milk cows milk cows I don't want to play
all right now this is Derek you go there
you go this is Stephen Hawking
this is called cow milking Derek
basically face each other Derek s L&S
are buttons Jim you're not pushing your
SL on us are buttons you push em you're
holding it upside down Jim it's
backwards cause it's Jim you say buttons
what he's doing is he's having it
backwards and then he's flipping it
upside down in the other hand the EDS
milk start milking guys start milking
Jim milk milk Jim milk a cow came
[ __ ] dare
champion milking Josh okay yeah I know I
put a skirt on the coward that's not the
first time you've milked after pouring
milk lemonade Derek you know what's
around the corner this is a great system
Travis I won thank God I made four cups
of milk Jim just Eric only made one cup
of milk go to replay oh wow
Jim came in in the end see Derrick
started really strong milking he got his
one cup early but Jim not fun Jim kid
went wrong
zelda yeah this is horrible wait before
you change it Travis yes the problem is
that Derrick one copy Dennis I don't
care if there's one at one time and Jim
one the milking game No
so we there should be some kind of time
break I can't I have too much OCD so
somebody needs to be to me I have to
here's the issue that has to be
addressed
yeah your OCD it doesn't make me play a
video game it's a good opportunity to
help you with your OCD okay we're
milking again Oh safe crack okay we can
do Kurt Jim play quick-draw how do I
pick don't be a spoil sport about it
Jesus Christ what's that guy wearing
he's wearing shorts and a tank top and a
[ __ ] cowboy hat okay how do you draw
him your register how do you dare akhir
register this is gonna be good you ready
you ready Derick look each other in the
derek has his hands in his fake holster
look at each other in the eyes know what
it's it's lower you're Derek look eye to
eye Oh Jim you shot your gun that's the
first time you jump the gun again
you jumped you're gone again oh sorry
the winner Jim no you you you shot your
gun off too early and then the wrong
direction I mean shoot at the chair you
shot in the wrong direction
Derrick you got to feel good you just
one switch copy dance yeah and
quick-draw but lost milking what's the
name of the of the game won you won the
one to switch competition away one to
switch is worse than I thought you don't
like it it's horrible it really is -
I've never liked anything less